what's up guys bang-bang what's up get
your lunch money right I literally don't
know what's going on right
I am shook because I was just surprised
by this comedian while Wall Street's
trying to get rich the rest of us trying
to get our lunch money right and plane
is trying to be a smartass
she obviously has rated the female
version of my closet well that's really
my shirt yes you look as joe said this
is the original comp collection so get
your lunch money right let's talk about
all he'll what's going on with the oil
it's negative negative prices Isis
explained oil all right so oil yeah so
they come I do basically they're gonna
pay me to take barrels of oil okay we
talked about this yesterday what was
your first question what was my foot oh
where are you gonna put it no why can't
prices go negative yeah why can't prices
go do you remember because there's too
much the sugar supply not enough demand
so they are literally running out of
places to put it nice so the whole thing
with the oil market right now is
basically there's OPEC which determines
how much gets produced everyone agrees
sometimes they disagree Russia and Saudi
Arabia basically produce so much oil
that they push down the price of oil
under the amount of production cost for
US shale oil producers so US shale oil
producers can't produce oil profitably
or actually losing money when they
produce on top of that there was the
corona virus which drew a or drove a
much lower demand for oil so you're not
driving your car you're not flying all
the things that consume a lot of oil and
so therefore as they kept producing oil
think of it as just supply and demand
demand drops but supply stays constant
then obviously the price is gonna have
to drop what we saw yesterday though was
physically settled oil futures contracts
so okay can I ask
where if I if I'm interested in getting
paid for taking barrels of oil are there
places you have to put it or can I just
literally put it in my apartment well so
think you gotta think about this isn't
like people just buying one barrel right
what instead they're doing is they're
buying hundreds or thousands or hundreds
of thousands of barrels lot of time so
we're talking millions of dollars of
this stuff and the whole idea behind a
physically settled futures contract is
it's a futures contract that has an
expiration date so the expiration date
for the May futures contract was April
21st today and so yesterday if you had
this contract you basically either said
I'm gonna sell it today to somebody else
or if I'm holding it tomorrow I have to
agree to take the delivery of the oil in
the contract in May so let's say that
for an easy example had a hundred
barrels of futures contract I could have
sold that yesterday morning for ten
dollars per contract or $1,000 but if I
don't have a place to put the oil right
when it gets delivered I can't hold the
contract because I'm gonna have to take
delivery so I'll sound like wall sell
for eight dollars and 7.6 off but I'll
sell it for nothing like just just take
it wait I'll pay you to take it five
dollars I'll pay you 20 bucks dude I'll
pay you 50 dollars to take this contract
so that you're holding it when it
expires and you take the delivery of the
oil not me so that's what happened
yesterday in the oil futures contract so
that's why the price of oil dropped to
negative
I'm literally paying you to take this
contract off my hands now this leads to
the question of well where do people
keep the oil so there's things like
warehouses where it's just lower they
put it there's reservoir so you can put
lots and lots of oil in a reservoir but
there's even places where they're
literally boats or tankers that have oil
on them that are just floating around in
the ocean right now because there's
nowhere for people who want the oil
there's just a surplus and so ends up
happening is like this is probably gonna
be very short-lived the price is never
gone below zero right because think
about a student well think about a stock
like a stock I'm holding whichever at
Disney issue I'm holding Disney stock
Disney can go to zero but that means the
company's worthless now but I can't go
negative right Disney is not gonna pay
me to take their working stock but
because it's a physical commodity I'll
literally pay you yesterday to take this
off my hands and so now what's happening
also is like the government is stepping
up so the US government is saying
a second we have strategic reserves
we've got some space but have a ton of
space we have some space so they're
actually gonna accept some of the oil as
well so literally we're in a world where
demand for oil is going down kind of
over a long period of time
electric cars all that kind of stuff but
the production for oil has stayed
constant right and now in the
coronavirus times demand fell off a
cliff
crushing taste comments now but one
saving grace before we move on is that
Russia and Saudi Arabia have both agreed
to cut production right so if they
decrease the amount of production the
price should stabilize and go up a
little bit but do you really want to
count on Russia and Saudi Arabia doing
what they said they were gonna do do you
agree that they're gonna cut 9 million
barrels in production today like there's
a lot of questions in there so it's just
really really interesting but you know
as I said Wall Street was talking a lot
of [ __ ] about crypto and other asset
classes over the last couple of years
there's not a single [ __ ] coin that went
to under right there's nothing no other
assets do this other than things like
physically settled futures contracts
seeing a lot of firsts for sure do you
want to buy a barrel of oil and put it
in the apartment what are we gonna do it
well they'll pay us 50 bucks and we can
buy dinner we could have a barrel of oil
and get dinner for free yeah you wanna
do it
are you sure no why oh you're not sure
no I'm sure if I confuse you enough can
we just have a barrel show up okay
what's going on with the Cheesecake
Factory so Cheesecake Factory cake cake
cake cake cake if you're going to dress
like me then I'm gonna act like you
annoying go ahead
so the Cheesecake Factory was really
struggling and they said they will not
be paying rent in April and luckily for
them a private equity firm called war
capital swooped in and invested 200
million dollars what do you think the
opportunity Warsaw and Cheesecake
Factory was every single company will
trade at some price this is the whole
lie that Wall Street has perpetuated
right that'll work
yeah perpetuated which is they're
sitting there saying oh we gotta bail
out the companies you gotta bail off the
compas you've got to bail out the
companies no we don't there are
investors in both the equity in the debt
markets that will buy these companies
who are loaning them money to buy shares
with them and the money it's just gonna
be a terms that the companies don't like
because the companies have gone from
being a price maker meaning I set the
prices that comes you up price taker
she's gonna be an economics major by the
end of this and so the whole idea is
Cheesecake Factory is in trouble they
say we're not gonna pay our rent we
don't have the capital investors look up
and say hey I have capital
I'll give you capital if I get good
terms or terms that I think are fair and
therefore roark a prophetess they
thought that hey these are fair terms so
they're gonna put capital in Cheesecake
Factory now strengthens their balance
sheet they should be able to pay rent
keep their employees do all the things
they need to do we don't need the
government to bail these companies out
let the market go to work and let
investors do what investors to that's
why the market works because again the
government's the idiot in the room
they're gonna give sweetheart deals and
we don't need them to happen so fun
facts the other day we were talking our
friends and I think was it you then
asked the question if yet to pick one
restaurant tea every day for the rest of
your life what would it be
forget what I said I said she's gonna
know our friend Ali said Cheesecake
Factory which is smart because there's
such a rich menu right Cheesecake
Factory is like I think in rap songs
they're like I'll take it to the
Cheesecake Factory that's like a it's
just high-quality enough to get you
credit for taking her to a nice
restaurant but it's just low quality
enough where it's not gonna really hurt
the wall on that I had I had my 15
you're been on a date to Cheesecake
Factory
you have no I don't think I think I'd go
in to the Cheesecake Factory once I
walked in it it's small Bennett left
cheesecake now you've really never been
coming to you you're gonna conky or
Benihana oh maybe huh a man Benihana
is so good all right what's the next
make up speaking of mega-rich Benihana
is for the mega-rich but what's going on
here this is just like a weird crazy
story you sent me but Silicon Valley's
mega rich are fleeing to New Zealand on
this like private island during the
crowbars well New Zealand's not a
private there's a private island off of
New Zealand are you sure yes I think
there's going to New Zealand cuz these
okay well why he key island yeah but
that's not where they're going that's
just what it's called it's considered a
billionaires playground all of New
Zealand is but the reason why New
Zealand is is because a lot of people
believe it's the safest place in the
world in terms of if anything bad goes
on it's so far away from everything else
and there's so much ocean in jobs they
don't good job containing it and also a
lot of people I think like Peter Thiel
and a bunch of other people have
previously bought very large properties
there or mansions they've got you know
bunkers and safe rooms and all this kind
of crazy prepper type stuff but now all
sudden coronavirus hit and stories are
coming out that people ran to New
Zealand to stay safe would you go to New
Zealand
oh right now we're just in general both
right now would you go No why not I
don't want to get on the plane okay
would you go in safe non-current exams
why I go to Waikiki Islands you were the
billionaires play just want to see okay
let's move on to Tom Brady speaking of
mega rich mr. Brady who is a complete
sellout for leaving the Patriots but go
ahead
so Tom Brady boom great greatest
quarterback of all time probably I'm a
Giants fan but I will give you the
credit
yeah like literally what are you doing
leaving the Patriots in Bill Belichick
but he is the greatest of all time most
likely and so you got to give him a tip
of the cap got to respect the greatness
so Tom Brady was working out in Tampa at
a closed park so some like police or
whatever saw this individual was spotted
working out finding himself in the park
and they went over to saying hey man
like you can't work out here and then
they're like oh [ __ ] it's breeding
so a like multi time NFL champion
quarterback was working out at a random
public park in Tampa that had been
closed if you don't have a house he
probably does it's probably a big house
because he needs more room than that
most likely and so and so imagine being
the police officer that shows up Oh sir
Sir sir you have to leave the park and
he turns on its breathing what do you
think they said I don't know like oh
sorry mr. breeze
get it can I get a autograph please they
told him to leave and then the city of
Tampa tweeted sorry Tom Brady our Tampa
Parks and Rec team can't wait to welcome
you and our entire community back with
even bigger smiles I've been you they
didn't tell Billy with a smile but it's
for like if you're that officer do you
ask him for an autograph no you can't
why well honestly if it was me I
wouldn't even know who that was maybe it
was Tom Brady I would but like I'd be
I'd be all professional be like listen
mister sir I did not expect her to drop
that oh man
all right royal birthday let's just
because your father
you can't Evo I have not taught her that
she learned that on our own
all right what's going on with the Royal
birthday okay so um Queen Elizabeth's
birthdays it's today birthday its
birthday it's today she turns 94 and the
saddest part is the gun salute was
cancelled because of coronavirus how is
she still alive I so there's this great
ship in 94 more like two decades this is
a great name of Queen Elizabeth's
shaking hands like every US president
and all those presidents are like long
dead and she's still here but she's like
the real Queen yeah why she like runs
the country well kinda yeah but like my
whole question is is it all of their
wealth take it as a tax like they get
paid per person in both England and also
other places right like Austria
Commonwealth so like this is pretty
crazy that there's really a queen she
gets she gets paid millions of dollars a
year simply is a tax on regular Joe's
she's been 94 for like three decades and
she seems pretty chill look at her she
yeah yeah but like when you're that old
do you like you think you have like
power problems like like you like oh my
god I need power I'm the queen everyone
I'll shut up in here um so I think she
used to be like that I think she's that
kind of loosen things up a little bit
because you know Prince Harry and Megan
Omar
cool that whole situation they recently
what is it called like gained
independence from the Royals they
bounced they were like we're out this is
ridiculous
you guys keep trotting us out like we're
little puppets and they were like we're
noir to Los Angeles she was young but
now she's just kind of like I don't need
to be part of your drama like do
whatever you're gonna do I'm just gonna
live my life you know who she kind of
reminds me of them
it was Carole [ __ ] Baskin cuz they're
both all did look weird and they both
have power pride issues okay I don't
understand why the Queen has a husband
but he's not the king that's the part
that I'm very confused about because I
don't think so if she's the queen even
though her husband he's not considered a
king cuz he doesn't come from the royal
blood blood man why all the world people
used to live in like if you should just
wake up and be like I'm the king cuz my
father is the king like I won the
ovarian Lottery you peasant go fetch me
food you would you would have been like
that if we live I've been the court
jester yeah come here sir and I would
come in and do like a little jig or
something and tell couple jokes and they
beg go back to your quarters and then I
run away in my little tights and go eat
some pork or something yeah look out the
window and wonder where is princess
Polina alright is there anything else
that you would like to say the people we
finished very fast today five minutes
not a lot of topics oils negative
Cheesecake Factory got some money
mega-rich are fleeing to New Zealand Tom
Brady is just being a stud in Tampa
going to the park saying [ __ ] your rules
and the Royals
you cursed earlier I can do whatever I
want and guys just so you know Polina
will not be wearing this attire tomorrow
we're gonna have a conversation that she
rated my cause I think that's my do you
remember
readers room readers was that it was
like you were like snatched into this
van
yes television yes and then you would
date girls or no no but this actually
just sounds like sex trafficking where
they just kidnap you and you're dating a
girl is that not what that is no not not
to make fun of sex drive but it's very
serious we should address it but like
you waiting a van was like two other
guys and then they send a girl to all
three guys's rooms and then she raids
them and she's like oh my god he has a
kabillion black t-shirt it's like why
would I want to date him and do they fix
your room for you oh they just make fun
of your PQ bass that sounds stupid all
right
anything last words for the people be
kind to your friends we appreciate you
guys watching lunch money every day noon
is why ish because we got our [ __ ]
together before noon afternoon right at
noon or 5:00 p.m.
well Wall Street is trying to get rich
the rest of us just trying to get our
lunch money right if you're gonna try to
say what I say then you have to learn
the words right we'll see you guys
tomorrow